my name is a little man hello my name is
John water and we're going to talk about
particular concern and things cases
which are met wrong with an infusion of
a language
okay so hi everyone thank you for being
here for this talk and today we're going
to talk about some of the latest
advances in the domain of natural
language understanding in the in the
Wolfram language and in particular the
function find textual answer and takes
cases
so before I want to tell few words about
what natural wedge and understanding is
that is I mean basically a sign and even
for that for natural processing so
there's many tasks that would fall into
this field
an example is entity recognition so the
goal is to in a text annotate or label
each word I mean at least some word
around entity for example here Northern
Ireland is an annuity division here
there's a date this is the number here
you have music work and person music
general and so on country very classic
that's one task another task is passing
to a symbolic representation so here I
have an example of grammatical parsing
well the goal is to tell the gram
chromatically unit of each word and by
the way there is a function in in a long
way context structure that does does
this this is not new question answering
is another natural language
understanding tasks where you have a
piece of text okay and then you have
question about this piece of text and
and the goal is to answer the question
summarization of one of these tasks
language modeling so a word modeling is
to have a model that can generate text
according to the distribution of natural
language so typically we would model to
probably differ the next character given
the past one translation a lot of these
tasks the load generation another one
and we have a long history at work from
research in the domain of natural
language understanding especially
because of all from alpha where the
Morpher modifier I'll show you all used
so the goal is you type a question in
natural language and one from artifact
we need to understand this question in
order to be able to query database and
answer the question so and and then
because of a from alpha we have a lot of
let's see children function so here it
it from the ocean for technology such as
interpreter so interpreter is you can
say I know it's a city
the string is NYC what is what is the
city and it represented as an entity and
then you can call properties and things
like that freeform input is also so if I
do control equal my charm
you know this computer better than me
maybe it's time to leave the full screen
its culturally qualified something else
no it's control equal
okay well if you do culturally cool and
you can type something at a language and
it will interpret it as continue to
drive and it will and it will give it
basically the war from a long wait
expression to perform action you wanted
to do you go from screen are always
problem so if I want to say I don't know
okay classic yeah integrates you know
sign X from from two to three okay and
it will interpret it as a motion or
expression and then you can evaluate it
grammar apply is also something heritage
from from Oh from alpha it's a way for
you to to define grammars for example
here it's okay the the kind of a
sentence that are trying to pass well
there will be in in fixed order further
ad then there will be a token which is
semantics number then another token with
a non symmetric number and and then you
perform this action and if you put
grammar apply and apply it to this
sentence it will pass so it will
understand this sentence and then
performed the operation and one thing
that is important to know is that what
from alpha technology is mainly this
type of technology which which is so
it's mainly manual programming which is
like a extremely big piece and an
impressive piece of technology and and
the reason we did I mean I wasn't there
but we did know from research the
solution that it's the only one that
works to perform this type of task and
for very long time only this type of
solution were efficient to do natural
weight understanding but recently as
you've been all where there's been a big
push to instead of having encoded
solution to have learned solution and
the reason is well it's one one is that
it's more in fashion and people annotate
so we have better data we have more
computing power and there's also a lot
of research in your network that allowed
to let's not go into much detail but
that allowed to kind of express more of
program knowledge you have about the
problem and and take advantage your data
as good as as possible and and that's
why we decided to kind of start
introducing this type of solution for
natural language policing in the water
language and angiogram will start
presenting some of these solution yeah
so I start with a fun textual answer so
it's about question answering so you
give a piece of text and you want to ask
question about this text so for example
here I have a text about some city and
Russia where it's cold and I'm asking a
bunch of questions on it then I call
find textured answer here is write to
show which answer question to which
question okay so it's entering the
question so this is based on a neural
network as Ian mentioned so of course
it's not perfect also so here that there
is another example where I give a book
The Phantom of the Opera I asked who is
how so it's taking more time because the
book is big and okay it and saw
something that maybe can make sense like
but a Christian is not wrong obviously
so to talk a bit about the technology
behind so first it's in a two-step
procedure so there is a tf-idf bias the
filtering to if the text is an input
stick is very big to select a few
paragraph because the neural networks
are a bit expensive to to run even if
it's improving so first here based on
the words of the question and among the
text we are going to select some
paragraph and then on the piece of text
or on
on the top paragraph that are selected
after this election we run a neural
network which is this one
so we developed it with our framework so
it's an L graph a graph of layer like
this and maybe I briefly and you have to
describe briefly as it works so first we
divide the text into words then each
word in is not into a semantic vectors
so called water meetings then there is a
recurrent Network on it which mean after
the oricon know a network yourself one
vector tell words but it depends on the
context take it context dependent word
embeddings then there is a some
attention mechanism so dashing mechanism
is when you have a sequence of objects
and you have got a query and given the
query you are going to assign weights to
put all these objects to get a unique
vector representation of the full
sequence so that's why we are doing and
we are doing the two way so the context
attend the question and the question
attend the context like you issue you
are asked to question you can ask a
paragraph that having the question in
mind and then you can reread the
question once you write the power the
passage also to interpret the context of
the question given the paragraph small
as the idea and then after the attention
again recurrent our networks because it
is very good and then some point on
networks which are going to assign to
each world a probability that the answer
start and ends here and then after we
apply your constraint to choose the best
segment of text that will enter there
there's a question yeah there is a blog
if you want to more explain explanation
so the training data it was mainly a
squad which is the famous that I said
for question answering it was about
100,000 paragraphs from Wikipedia and
actually this that I said at the
beginning it was challenging but after
like the Machine started to to achieve
the human performance and the program of
the data set is that the way it was
created like passages were are giving to
people and and they have to to make a
question out of this passage so first it
that the question the answer is always
in this passage and also by the way
stone-like yeah nobody you don't know if
the answer is in your text so so it's
not very realistic
that's why fun texture ons are also not
operating very good and also if you yeah
the model that are trained we we didn't
know not only train on Wikipedia but if
you train on Wikipedia then if you put a
text that is more free than Wikipedia
with miss bearings this kind of stuff
and it does not look like Wikipedia it's
always the problem of machine learning
like girl your training that has to be
representative of that vacation you want
to build so it works well for Wikipedia
like text but not always good but yeah
we are going so it was 11 knots week
fine-textured and so there was no
improvement for this version but for the
next one there was a new squad data set
where they realized like let's make it
harder data set with unanswerable
questions so we are going to retrain for
the next version another integration of
fent texture enter now let's switch to
Tex cases so chen will introduce the
project ok so it takes case it is not a
new function actually it's almost three
years old I believe we introduced it
although we kept it experimental for all
this time because the very ambitious
function so the goal is to do named
entity recognition but actually as g1
will show after not just for six type as
it's usually under a set like city
country person location things like that
but more for three hundred times and and
of course this gives these challenges so
let me quickly kind of remind one st.
acts of Tex Cadiz so so the idea is that
you the first argument is some text here
grab the Wikipedia page of champagne and
then second argument you can ask for
something you look for for example I'm
looking for all the person in in
champagne and this buzzed way is running
the new version okay so what if you say
that we need a big update in 12 that's
why we are we are talking about it
day okay so we have all the persons but
you can also specify output type you can
say oh actually I want this person to be
interpreted in our entity representation
and okay so some interpreted somehow not
because we don't have entities for them
so there's an option that we just
introduced this called verify
interpretation so here it makes sure
that only return result that are in our
in our system and you can also give
several properties so here I'm going to
say return the position the string and
interpretation for all of these all
these persons alright so you know it
also gives the role of text position and
and so on and what you can do also is
several types so on all the person and
all the countries and this is something
we change for twelve now it will return
an association where there's a key for
person a key for country and then over
over all the result you can see person
and you have all the results for persons
and then country and all the results for
country containing is another
interesting thing for text cases where
you can say okay I want all the sentence
all the sentences that contain a person
and you can also use things like
verbatim which would be the equivalent
of a exact string match so here it would
be okay so this is all the sentences
this will be okay let's unravel that
this other person that contain it's a
little presence you did for me that's
person that have a surname that contains
CK okay well that's interesting query so
you know you can mix like exact string
match and most semantic type okay so
that's how this works and and and as I
was saying in version 12 we the big
now it's it's a big neon network behind
it and we have many more types and so
Jerome is going to oh no first speak
about text content okay because with
this big updates we decided to enter
your new function is called text
contents but it's easier to use because
you just give some text shift enter and
it will try to tell you a bit everything
that it knows about this text so it's
more computer to human function you know
it returns data set and you can eyeball
it and you can actually discover what
text cases can do but I assume that case
takes cases would be more actual
function being used and so you can see
here
okay so champagn identified as a city it
was in first position it has a
probability that's one of the advantage
of having a statistical solution so in
that case in your network is that now we
have a probability so actually there's
an option and I forgot to mention is
this acceptance threshold so you can set
an acceptance threshold and let's say I
put accident threshold of 0.95 then I
should have these quantities for example
the right that I going away so let's see
acceptance threshold what's going on
yeah I can't see the lecture so that's
okay complete you don't see the cursor
anyway 0.95 okay so here to only only
keep what it's really confident and
actually not well that's a problem 12 is
not out yet so I'm going to solve that
but it's pretty easy to filter by
probability and this will be done okay
and all right so we're saying there's
many many more type and so Jerome is
going to present about it yeah so as I
didn't say there are about more than 300
types in total so Indian we made a guide
page like the interpreter types and
entity types to document all of them
because to be coming so much too much so
we make some some sections so that you
the user can find what he wants into it
so I'm going to present all the all the
types more or less how to demo it so
text content by by default II is taking
a set of types that we thought it was
good to draw some semantic content like
entities quantity colors dates this kind
of stuff but you can impose function you
can specify the type you want and what
we achieve actually what she was not
possible in the previous Russian which
was based on the spellings for for this
kind of things entities is that there is
disambiguation like you see the word
Doug in this example so model is
understanding that the first dot is
referring to the animal so it's called
it's a species type and the second how
in hotdog is referring to food so it's
the it's yeah one of the good feature
about it so okay as the appian mentioned
there are entities so and and it's not
about a the six type of entity like
person like you can be take the entity
types that are in the world from
language for example here on the
wikipedia planets i detect all the
planet
often forcing now you can play with
accent a threshold
twinmas but you cannot change the priors
it's we could give a way for user to
specify some prior information they have
but it's a bit complicated there's so
many types and so you can have to define
the prior for everything we do that for
classifying you can have class priors we
should think about it maybe this way to
give a hint could be useful actually for
now if you specify performance goal goes
to speed it disabled the neural networks
and it will use some spellings so maybe
it's a way to achieve what you want okay
so I was about the planet so yeah you
can find a specify the type of entity
that you want but if you are looking for
one particular entity you can specify it
like here I'm not looking for all the
planet but on only Mouse and I'm asking
to reach on highlighted snippets around
the world on the world okay then there
are locations so here is also a page
about the drinking champagne I can
extract the location and I mask into it
on the string and the interpretation
which are your position in the case of
locations all the string that can be
interpreted as a location so countries
or cities and location is a generality
if you want a city or country the more
accurate a kind of location you can also
have it
item 12 yeah I mean big update in 12
it's already there but it's gonna work
much better in 12 day it's still
experimental will the experimental eyes
when you know we're confident that you
know everything works
okay there are some the quantity than
the number so it's detecting also the
numbers in VTR and here for example I
gave a message with some currency and
calling text content stinking the
currencies also yeah you can ask for an
output property but you can also make a
function like this which use the
property like this like here mi output
function is a rule from a string and I
take the interpretation which is the de
currency and then I convert to Dora and
then it will display the results in this
form so it's taking a bit of time to
render it interpreter and I are all my
currency into the lower
okay there are ideation elements like
person email address zip code URL this
kind of stuff then there are part of a
Majnu test or moody news text either
related to semantic like there are some
topics if you want music topics real
good library of topics so that you can
detect into a text or you can ask also
for the search for four pieces of text
in a particular language also
programming language or stuff and there
are some classical NLP where you can ask
for the part of speech like verb
pronouns and also web phrase so of here
it will do the same as text structures
just returning the results into another
another format and yet also warrant
sentences for those no texts and takes
the tenth text sentences sorry it's a
it's the same and for those who know
about tokenization which with each kind
of one of the thought process you do
when you do natural language processing
you can also add a as for text cases to
return what operation yeah we didn't
mention that alternative is also working
and it's faking a unique type so here
I'm asking role in punctuation and it's
tokenizing the text okay so do I have a
time
I have a bit of time to explain what's
another word I create it's a big machine
here I present like the main novelty but
you are still using some summary Greg
Greg axis calling the interpreter like
there are several passes a hybrid system
so he boot system yeah so yeah there are
other built-in classifier duvall are
already classifiers before that are plug
into it to to classify pieces of sex
with profanity or the sentiment the
topics the language in the programming
language and the big novelty that is the
is it non-networked do the design big
machine part so it's based originally so
again we build it without framework and
the depart point was a model released by
the alanine Institute called Elmo which
was doing contextual word embeddings so
yeah you have a world-first you do the
angular embedding where each word is
mapped into a vector independently of
the context no actually I start again
actually it's a character based model so
there is no yeah one good point about
this model and is needed from Gd there
is no out of vocabulary because when you
have a lookup table with words if the
world is not in your training data set
your step you cannot recognize anything
so this is a character based word
embeddings
so it's the characters which are mapped
to vectors then there is a convolutions
actually there are several convolutions
in parallel that you see here with
several filter size which doing ngrams
of characters like it's taking the
characters around the the paris and the
tables of character etc then we pulled
off one representation of the world and
then like you are not networks okay and
in the end it gives another network and
the first layer how's the same you can
see that there are difference like you
don't see sister but this is an
optimization detail like I packed all
the convolutions together to make a
unique conversion with some zeros in the
filters just to be faster but if you if
you retraining then the zero not become
zero and it's fat equivalent and for the
training data set so this was the big
work to make that
I said to train these networks so here
we will also use the mainly Wikipedia
like 300,000 pages we use the knowledge
base of Wolfram Alpha like here because
one from Alpha when you type your
research is papaya when you type request
it's parsing this request and then
assigning it to each word linking each
row to the knowledge right based so we
used this we also use the links in
Wikipedia to make disambiguation
like on this page of mass of mercury
mercury is referred to as a planet
sometimes he has a mythology as a and if
you follow the link and you look at the
bottom of the Wikipedia page you will
see the category and it helps to
disambiguate the world in context so
it's kind of a mix of many what Martha
knowledge thing from Wikipedia some
other secret sauce that you know we'll
talk about and okay so to conclude very
quickly so you can take few questions as
we talk about Fantasia Lancer takes
cases takes content and takes it is very
big update text content is new and we're
pretty happy with the result neural
network solution give us so we'll
continue but that's really the beginning
so so we will improve fun textual a lot
I believe including text Casey steak
content it's kind of almost our first
experiments although I know you worked a
long time on it and and then we'll
tackle over enough to bootstrap exactly
we have to bootstrap we have there are
many IDs to include more knowledge from
all four alpha into it and then we won't
take a lot - such as summarization and
translation and make all that available
for all languages which is not a easy
feature but we'll try to do make it
happen
okay is there some question